- HI.
- WE WANTED TO PURCHASE
A PLANE.
- AN AIRPLANE?
- YES.
IT'S JUST THAT WE INVITED
AXL ROSE AND TYRESE
ONTO OUR PLANE,
AND THEY DID SOME "DERMAGE."
- YAR.
- WELL, I'M SO SORRY TO HEAR
ABOUT YOUR PLANE,
BUT WE DON'T SELL WHOLE PLANES.
WE JUST SELL SEATS.
- OKAY, LET US PURCHASE TWO
FIRST-CLASS TICKETS, PLEASE,
TO DUBAI.
- DUBAI.
- WE NEED TO GET
TO THE DUBAI FILM FESTIVAL.
- MM-HMM.
- WE'VE GOT A SHORT-SUB DOC
ABOUT THE PLIGHT
OF THE IRAQI PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN BEVERLY HILLS.
- OKAY, WELL, I HAVE
ONE FLIGHT LEFT OUT TO DUBAI.
IT LEAVES IN AN HOUR
AND A HALF.
AND I HAVE TWO SEATS
AVAILABLE
IN COACH.
[dramatic crescendo]
- OKAY.
- I MEAN, IT'S IRONIC
THAT WE'RE FLYING COACH
TO THE MIDDLE EAST,
BECAUSE I "DERFINITELY"
FEEL LIKE A MARTYR.
- OH, MY GOOBERS.
WHAT IS THIS?
OH...
- WE FORGOT THAT WE HAVE TO
GO THROUGH SECURITY.
- I'M SORRY,
DO WE STILL HAVE TO DO THIS
IF WE KNOW GOD IS DEAD?
- YOU KNOW WHAT, WENDALLS?
WE'VE GOTTA GET RID
OF A FEW THINGS.
- YEAH.
OKAY...WHALE AMBIEN.
- YOU CAN TAKE THAT, RIGHT?
I MEAN, IT'S IN THE SHAPE
OF A CRESCENT MOON.
IT WOULD BE RESPECTFUL.
BYE-BURR.
- FUN GUN.
- NOW, WAIT.
IS THAT OUR ACTUAL GUN,
OR IS THAT GUN WE USE
TO SHOOT SCHNEEF
RIGHT INTO OUR BLOODSTREAM?
- NO, THIS IS SUPER HEAVY.
I THINK IT'S REAL.
- YEAH, THIS IS REAL.
- BYE.
- BURR-BURR.
[gunshot]
- ORIGINAL COSTUMES FROM
THE MOTION PICTURE DICK TRACY.
- NO, KEEP THOSE.
BOO-YAKA-SHAH.
- OMG!
- HEY, TOM THANKS,
LET'S DO A FORREST BUMP.
- MMM.
- [snorts]
[coughs]
OOH...
- AHH!
SCHNEEF. IT'S WHAT'S FOR DINNER.
- [chuckles]
THE OTHER WHITE SCHNEEF.
- OOH.
- OKAY, REST IN SCHNEEF.
I'M GOOD.
- HELLO, GENTLEMEN.
I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU
YOU ARE SITTING
IN AN EMERGENCY EXIT ROW.
ARE YOU WILLING
AND ABLE TO ASSIST
IN THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY?
- YAR. YAR.
- CAN YOU OPERATE
THE EMERGENCY DOOR?
- UHHHH...
[both laugh]
- CAN YOU OPERATE
THE EMERGENCY DOOR?
- AAH!
- JUST A "YES."
- DEFINITELY.
- TURTALLY.
[both laughing]
- I'M SORRY?
- DEFINITELY.
- TURTALLY.
- SAY YES.
- YARN!
- DOES--DOES THAT MEAN YES?
- YEAH.